you spent many years formative part of
your career
working for and with republicans
and i'm curious because i'm trying to
look
forward now the specifics of what
happens
tonight or tomorrow in the next few days
we can't say right now we think we know
what's going to happen but let's look
farther forward what does the republican
party
do now because there are a lot of people
like myself
i'll be honest with you i say this i
must have said this a million times
i don't get as angry at donald trump
because i look at him
as uh i think a lot of people would
agree a malignant narcissist
was the term which is used a lot he's
someone who has a condition
um probably needs to be treated the the
people i
reserve my true anger for are the
enablers within the republican
party who have just gone along and it
they've all been in lockstep
and i'm i'm sort of a history buff i'm
hard-pressed to think of another
president
that had the total zombie-like control
of his party like donald trump
not no one breaks ranks they're all
terrified of him
so what happens how does the republican
party
move forward from this point or do they
not is it going to be
still trump's party look this is my
private pain
usually i mean this party that
justifiably gave the bush family um
and you and i've talked about this
before uh who i worked for such a hard
time
never hesitated to criticize an
effective and that was healthy i you
know i'm not complaining about that i'm
just saying i know the republican party
is capable of saying screw you to a
republican president because i saw it
um to see them be so subservient
uh in the face of a man who doesn't
believe in anything they believe in and
you can argue
that the base of the party's more where
trump is on foreign policy
and trade that might be true but the
republican elected officials are not
they believe the stuff that former
republicans and former republican
nominees used to believe in
so to have sort of capitulated on their
own
ideology and then to capitulate it on
their own
souls is to me the most dangerous
dynamic
in the era of trump because what's
happening right now
is that people around trump are saying
it's over
it's not clear to me that anyone has
walked in and told him that he may have
figured it out because he watches
he's an incessant consumer of cable news
and i think even on
fox news while some of the folks in the
evenings they're cheering these
really sort of illogical and and
non-forms
i mean in one state they want the vote
to keep going and another they wanted to
stop and another
they want ballots stuck in i mean you
know they don't want one thing across
country so
the fact that so many people allow him
to um really desecrate the presidency
is to me the irreparable piece of his
tenure
which looks like it'll only be four
years but i don't think there is
something on the other side
it's it's you know how do you build that
back if you if you're successful i mean
not something on the other side for the
republicans because that's my curiosity
is
for these republicans right if you're
and i i
have friends people i went to college
with so we we didn't agree
on they're smart uh you know they're
very intelligent
well-read uh people who have who really
love their country
who uh we didn't always see eye to eye
because they would vote republican
uh i would vote democrat but
we would have long conversations and we
shared a lot of values
and now i think we've gotten to the
point where um
those people those friends of mine have
wanted no part of trump or trumpism
so you wonder is how does the republican
party
how does it encapsulate or how can it be
big enough a big
tent that holds reasonable people
and people that believe in their hearts
that joe biden
is a pedophile and drinks the blood of
children in satanic rituals how do you
do that i don't know that there's a
party there
well look i mean that's a q a um
conspiracy
i didn't know what q anon was until very
recently i mispronounced them i saw them
in my teleprompter and called them
like queen on one on
um look i don't think it's oil and water
right q anon is a toxin
and i don't think you can say like oh
i'll just swim with them
so it is it is they are mutually
exclusive
and what the party has become doesn't
have room for reasonable people
i think the smart line of questioning
that you're pursuing
is at this point unknowable
because i think that winning campaigns
always overread their mandate
and senate republicans will think they
won this
because they didn't lose as many seats
as they thought and even if donald trump
is rejected i think they will misread
what might have been a lot of anxiety
about shutdowns
and about maybe over i think republicans
have been conditioned to believe
that shutdowns and lockdowns and public
health
safety measures are against the
interests of our economic
security and i think that is not what
joe biden has been saying
but i think that's where that sort of
toxic
mix of disinformation and misinformation
and painting all democrats
as socialists has will make it difficult
for him to lead the whole country
because i think half the country truly
thinks he wants to to shut people down
and leave them in their homes
that is not even the public health
approach but
i i think that until you have a party
that understands that that dynamic
worried about the economy worried about
the shutdowns had more to do
with republicans looking healthier on
tuesday night and some of these senate
races than even a lot of republicans
thought they might
than any sort of mandate for trump or
trump ism or what they're doing
um i think they will continue down this
path and i think flirting with q and on
and playing footsie with white
supremacists
is it is it is a dead end road it's a
cul-de-sac there is no
what's the gop on the other side it has
to you know sort of
collapse and it might in the next cycle
of the cycle after that
and then you know maybe maybe something
thoughtful
comes up uh on the other side maybe it
doesn't you know
maybe we have this sort of corrupt half
of of
of the political you know machinery and
and maybe that's what democrats have to
figure out how to contend with
i don't see clearly what the future is
for the two-party system
you